I watched heavyweights recently where he
does that like he's like are we bowling
now Kenneth I forgot how good that movie
was it's like resident Knievel I need if
you're a first-time viewer welcome to
hell I was just saying yeah we're
playing through all the Resident Evil
games we are on resonable to remake the
most recent the most clearly the one I
know the best last episode I'm glad I'm
honestly I think I did a better guiding
you through the earlier games which I
haven't played in years than I did
through this one I think it was a
combination of you making like maybe
like one or two small mistakes but the
bigger thing was is we had really bad
luck like I had really bad luck with
like liquors being in places that I
thought were not there and we like
thought all sorts of things that were
wrong to be honest with you he's and if
you can hear him stomping on but he's
[ __ ] stomping around so you'll recall
at the end of last episode we got the
second electronic part from the clock
tower yes irony opens the door I'm like
where is he but he can't come in here so
yes let me let's talk about this I had
kind of a mixed bag last week because we
did accomplish many things but I also
got severely injured and I used like two
full heals I'm sure it's fine but I'm
you know I'm pushing it a little bit um
I did get a boxed electronic part here
yeah hey really quick sorry is your the
screen on my end screen shared thing
yeah shows you when the bottom like the
corners cut off is that just me does it
look good on your end what is it say it
again what does it look
so the window I'm looking at the screen
you're sharing it shows that you are cut
off like all it literally it's it's crap
dude short
I'm OBS I am not cropped out so ok my
screen it's a bit unnerving but as long
as what I'm recording looks good we're
good as long as the viewers get what
they want no I was where Brooklyn lager
in my life again they don't go to
California that's nice they're also a
sponsor of the show now so uh if you've
no I'm just kidding we don't have
sponsors that would be cool though we
have no sponsors GameSpot's been
sponsoring us for too long I keep
waiting for them to change their minds I
heard actually watch the show and
realize they should cancel it they're
trying to bump us to gameplay they might
have already I don't know oh my god I
heard someone told me in the comments
that even if you're not poisoned by
combining a blue herb with the red and
the green it gives you an additional
health boost so it's worth doing because
later we'll get more blue herbs for when
I actually get poison so they're like
just use them like don't yeah it like
increases your Constitution for a
limited time so when you take it it
doesn't do as much damage definitely I
should have told you a long time ago but
I forgot I don't
fun this is another thing people I've
been saying press the touchpad right now
just right now yeah I just tap it
another touchpad like that there you go
it organizes it our friendly who's been
a long time watcher of the show so thank
you my god I mean it helps right like
it's it's more on a gun powder holy [ __ ]
alright well let's talk about this game
arounds because we'll probably need
flame rounds later Lord so that and you
have a decent Monaghan good name right
now but yeah I think I'll get the other
electronic part
okay give me one second or it is I'll
[ __ ] itself about it oh no it's not yeah
you passed it was at the bottom okay
probably eat all these heels I have a
lot of heels I'm way combined that green
herb with the red and blue combined yes
okay so I have a full heel here let me
man yeah we [ __ ] up with the board's
probably it would have been so helpful
to use those boards back in the day to
avoid that hallway of death that I kind
of parted yeah I literally don't know if
I can do anything about it at this stage
like it's good I've said this probably
six times before I don't think you need
to go back that way for a while at least
but yes I think you're good inventory
wise so I have I have okay I have these
two boxed electronic thingies I have a
handgun a grenade launcher I only have
11 no I have 37 bullets I'm okay but I
only have two grenades what do you think
am I good yeah that's fine I don't even
think you have any green AIDS to bring
and you don't have any premium hand gun
powder whatever it's called
what's my objective I would unbox those
part you're literally going to the room
across the hall to put those electronic
parts in and get the garage key card I
believe rip open that tape like an
Amazon gift card no uh oops a couple
months ago as people know so I've been
getting Amazon boxes every day yeah this
sex toy I just have no idea what's
showing up at my door if you stopped
ordering them weekly it would be more of
a surprise definitely seems to be a
correlation between how much I buy on
Amazon and how much shows up at my
apartment strangely enough
I don't buy sex toys and I'm not saying
anybody that does under saying I prefer
to be in person at don't care
vibrations that was the name of the San
Francisco store that I walk by a lot
never one side though there's one in
Portland right by where I live called
she bop
it's like female friendly it's like what
it's called no I think they're all
female friendly but this one's like very
friendly female friendly cuz it's
literally called she bop so it's like
meant for ladies to like go in or
whatever I don't know I have not been in
yet but I delete it C Mon keeps trying
to go in okay we've been stuck in this
purgatory of a safe room rambling
forever let's why you saving you haven't
done anything all right organize my
inventory okay we're just going
literally across the hall that's where
they get you yeah that's never gone
wrong before
alright so I'm going into the what what
do you mean I tackle a private
collection room excellent point is the
electric panel is there a bad guy in
here I don't know it sounds like he's
upstairs I meant like a liquor you run
through the wrong yeah no I don't think
a liquor would be here I've been wrong
many times before and every time
well maybe seven well there's that sexy
piece of jungle ass actually that tiger
would not be in the jungle I'm sorry
good the plains actually no it would be
in the jungle I don't know
Tigers I'm just talking I don't drink
much anymore so this quarter of a beer
is bodes well for the rest of the
episode there you go oh there's a bear
those too late white spots okay so she
hey you just got it like a ratchet and
clank minigame actually okay i'm you're
just connecting
I believe you want to connect the purple
to both the blue and the red okay I
don't know you'll figure it out it's
it's less complicated than it looks yeah
yeah like there you go purple wait was
that not it I thought it was but here we
are
oh wait yeah go I think I'm honestly
doing more harm than good like telling
you how to do this you'll just figure it
out god damn it it's weird though
because it looks like that should be it
I guess I'm just a pawn I think it's
that one
yeah now go down I was I was gonna say
that but what's the puzzle that gave us
the more probable throughout the series
I'm trying to rob one that I had to do
twice because we died and I lost the
save and it you couldn't you couldn't
tell me how to do it because it was
random
I want to say it was from three it was
the end of resin evil zero at the end of
the Train part it's random I just
remember like very vividly so the train
and you told me speed runners had proud
oh yeah speed runners had to wait for
like the ideal situation like I couldn't
throw it I'm gonna turn it up
hello good to see you again Claire
Dominic's pizza are you doing
[Laughter]
I've been looking at my OBS screen which
is a mistake because it's got a slight
delay so oh it's tyrant for now why is
he so mean like what's his deal you read
he's a he's pretty much in on helping
umbrella test out their viruses and [ __ ]
the little girl is she's sherry Birkin
um she knows about [ __ ]
or she's res evil so there's a lot of
weird or things that don't make sense
but like that window [ __ ] idiot we go
sorry I'm sherry mmm-hmm in her stylish
short uniform but for real wore to the
Oscars yeah I remember that that was
when it was cool though ah when I was
that's not it King Dom her age we had
uniforms too and they were so like they
just did not do you any favors and I
like didn't wear them we had optional
uniform so I was like huh there must be
a way out and now wait oh nice a puzzle
of some sort oh you gotta go find the
piece so that she says there must be a
way out of here yeah and it's like and
there's a cardboard passageway it's like
Shawshank Redemption
no I don't
oh do I need I need a knife she can't
kick in the card oh my god it's the same
from Resident Evil 7 this is actually I
don't know if this was intentional but
this whole scenario
present evil seven but also it's like an
escape room like the ones in res navel 7
that game was so good alright so I think
I have to go out this way yeah no okay
well I don't know what to tell you what
else am I missing do I need a knife or
something yeah there's other stuff going
on classic little girl knife do the one
tip I've been telling you since the
first episode ever of the show Oh put
your fist up its butt yeah you're the
one that tried to sorry there we go okay
I like how she has four item spots for
grenades and everything alright let's
see okay okay okay
sorry I mean to do that did you I'll ask
you after Herman how do I back out you
can rotate them as well
would be uh oh I see okay I got it
yeah um alright so I need a square and a
circle
you know it's [ __ ] the one you just
put on the right side is a square and a
circle on that side yeah you got it did
you ever do those puzzles that were I
don't even know how to describe them let
me try
they were like struck Euler before yeah
that's what happened all the time
they're these triangular boards and
they're the pieces were all triangles
with certain things coming off the edge
kind of like this and you had to match
them up and it would always be like
where you get to the last two and you
realize you put all them in the wrong
spot like I don't know all like I'll go
at some point and tell people what's up
cuz they were they're fun but they're
infuriating all right for the record I
really think that was a cool puzzle
I can [ __ ] rip tape yeah I'm a big
girl
the same thing happened in resin evil 7
and earlier in this one with a yellow
tape on that electric box
I'm a bust baby I can do this and I
dance like a man I can shake on my fanny
I can shake him I can song huh
well our cat's name is Kong so we sing
the Kong song all the time and those
lyrics sounded suspiciously similar I
mean I love the idea that that could
have been the thong song but no it's not
it's from adventure time I only ever
watched like half a season of that it
was good I just never got it [ __ ] uh
Marcus Marcus Fenix what's Marcus his
last name from Gears of War look at my
characters yeah Marcus Fenix he was the
voice of the dog in an adventure time
they made her so meek yeah that guy's
amazing his voices are all incredible
she looks so skewed she's got like dirty
clothes
nope
can I hop scotch that's badass they
don't let her outside so she just draws
chalk on the carpet - [ __ ] you guys
we're rapidly approaching today's date
kind of oh well I'm not really is that
me or did someone write that on my
behalf cuz that doesn't seem like the
day she was having I don't know I am
amazing
all right look fire extinguisher good
never forget never forget are these
stairs at least let me sick if that was
a Knievel Easter Egg that they put in
there and purpose well this game was
made long before we got to that point
but whatever I'd like to think that most
of the things that the developers do
they do for us
yeah Oh get up there baby Shinji Mikami
came back to Capcom to say hey check
this series out let's see what we can
what kind of easier as we could throw
these doofuses this is important this
does definitely of a resonable 7-zip to
it
just some weird noises going on that
song it's fine
it's that clock
this is I don't like this area because
it looks like it's designed to cat and
mouse around like yes so it doesn't feel
good
yeah you are you're learning
remember the section in resonable for
where you play as ashley and you're kind
of going between the suits of armor and
[ __ ] it reminds me of that and you're
ducking under stuff are you learning
anything that's going on there were two
doors
there's the door over there two should
be going over there there's a door hey
check it out at least it might be locked
it's probably locked
those are huge blocks okay now we know
and there's these coffee pots and mugs
these babies drinking macchiatos that
was these science experiments they were
doing you don't you know she has a
caffeine allergy her bedtime is a solid
8 p.m. I where's that into it Jerry
remember those remember those foam I do
carpet things I do remember those I
don't remember
hanging out on him but I remember they
were always around all right something's
gonna happen okay
just one giant escape room yeah I know
Shari we're in this together no another
alligator crocodile crocodile alligators
are in China I think
we both know she ain't getting out of
here yeah she's dead she's so dead
I've seen a lot of horror movies and
little girls are always the first to go
I mean speaking of Shawshank Redemption
this reminds me of the Aria that comes
over the loudspeakers that one point and
not really knows okay where is he it's a
body is it a mannequin a billiard table
where is he and Eckhart
where are the [ __ ] keys for that desk
he's gonna hear that you're gonna make a
noise Oh Graham I told you no time to
teach some manners I don't know how they
work Oh is he gonna like mr.xu oh my god
this is like the plot of Matilda except
he's mrs. Trunchbull listen this is not
Matilda okay so I'd recommend going back
to the playroom to CAD Mouse and then
come back down to get the keys oh wait
does he have the keys
oh yeah the playrooms I mean who amongst
us doesn't regret acid so well he just
oh they blocked this [ __ ] off yeah just
use this
yeah who did that he's locking it oh
[ __ ]
do you remember this yes stealth stealth
pickpocket oh yeah for now just keep
hiding go around his toes get it off his
belt I have to oh no nevermind he's
letting you up sorry I shouldn't have
done that
yeah listen you big [ __ ] what still
there he just opened the path behind you
I think oh right I forgot
also I panicked oh this is fancy
not not not my best yeah wait am i dying
yeah you don't want that to happen at
least say he didn't kill you
oops I hit continue yeah you should you
should okay sorry I think that should
have been hard and it it wasn't
it wasn't hard I just think I panicked
with the system yes I got it this time
[Music]
did I do I have any more acid on me now
cuz that's what you want show yourself I
know you're in here the longer it takes
me to find you the worse it's gonna be
okay
so he moves this path and then I need to
run in it but I don't know where to go
once I run in the path you know like do
I move where he is now or for the door
take take a right after you go through
there and like hug the bookcase yeah so
yeah take a right but like stay close to
the book or like keep going all the way
down
now turn around and wait for him to to
do what he's gonna go through
I forget which door he's gonna go
through one of those doors and you just
gotta kind of take a left there's a
shelter right you can get behind if he
does come this way we're past this chair
oh wait oh yeah it was like fell onto
the thing I was talking about sorry this
is like no it's not that one don't worry
sorry
it's confusing I'm not sure where he
wants me to hide I mean typically after
I get caught I see it but I don't see it
until the until it's too late so where I
like still don't know what to do I know
to cat and mouse him the first time but
I don't know what to do the second time
so you went to the general the right
general area but the thing he fell on I
think you can't just get behind that and
wait for him to turn back around a great
trip
[Music]
okay so I'm gonna go to the right yeah
so is it in here oh I guess that works
but he might shine the flashlight in
there I mean you could try this but I I
think I was talking about behind that
brown thing right the area to your left
now she trips there yeah
so I gonna be fine right here when he
trips but as he covers his face and then
you just wait for him to go back like
he'll I don't know how much you want me
to tell you was gonna happen so when he
trips do I want to run around him no no
no no just just so okay yeah you
literally if you had not I mean it's
okay yeah now go
can I lock the door on him you know I
kind of wish though that would make
sense
I see
right yes use the key everyone's worst
nightmare when they're using a key do I
need the keys do I still have I think
I was mean
can I just lock it behind me because
that's what I should do
yeah I don't know oh you do there you go
very good [ __ ] ears chief irons
[Applause]
Ron sherry what the [ __ ]
so there was like a worm in his mouth
and I don't know a lot happened there I
feel and then he became mr. X not I'm
just kidding it's hers she misses it she
gave it to me where's that in the
neighborhood you'll find it
sherry all right click for now I swear
you bastard if you hurt her hot nice
good call you serious damn it damn you
Seinfeld oh cool so that was what I
needed to go downstairs yeah yeah yeah
dick all right so now what do I have
everything in here yeah I go save I mean
it's it had Auto saved anyway but still
worth saving probably gosh I think you
better that's this beginning the episode
all right so I want to just go right
back into the chef chief so I keep
calling him go into the chief's office
yeah okay
I probably Auto saved but there's no
harm getting some stuff done tell you
that right now all right so we need to
go to the downtown choose the elevator
right to your right right there's an
elevator in the chef's office what is
this wet discharge from the clouds
nobody ever will call it wet discharge
hey well now no I want every single
person who watches the episode to start
saying that spread it like a little fire
what is this
as far as I remember the battle [ __ ] no
just kidding
I just wanted to this episode was going
too smoothly me I just rate to that what
I was going to say was before you rid I
have not heard mr. X down here so I
don't think he comes down here like I
can't hear him
perhaps he's not allowed down here as
I'm trying to say it's
[Music]
mr. X wait why did you go through the
door I don't know oh my god there's a
lot you keep jinxing yourself with that
trench-coated [ __ ] yeah use that
obviously I'm gonna die I didn't think I
did I didn't think the door was gonna
open in time oh pretty degree or cure
right tara tara terregino can i ever
come back here cuz this is not the time
I think you'll get in do I ever come
back here you can but it'll be out of
your way
I do you got time you got I don't it's
literally okay so move the cursor like I
went up okay left down yeah down right
it's like right there
I don't have time for this [ __ ] you do
this it's not like that knife this is
like but you you took I don't think I
hurt you you had the blue I remember
your damage then yeah see the shield
yeah wait was it green or yellow would
you have done that without me is your
guy oh but it worked out alright I you
know where to go I don't want to get
punched
also let me know about herbs in advance
I'll try I just didn't see that until
you passed and I forgot about it you're
looking for the orphanage remember the
gun shop no gunshot I don't think he
left the station
you could easily dodge these two but am
I going in there oh where am I going huh
you and Claire are a better team than me
and you say hey I got you a green herb
you came out of that unscathed flaw it's
just first time since it happened
whoa it must be some sort of catwalk or
something oh that's a dog do you see
that you could expedite the process
should I shoot this person now or later
I think you could sneak around do you do
thank you duty - Dean - she's probably
making you say no but you keep trying
can she climb I don't think she might be
able to just go in hey these are
important questions yeah you're ready
for that other dog though right and he
munch he can go through that door so
kind of hurry it up
I bet you love this a shooting doll
anything to your hard right no it's uh
tire the tire what about this that's
also alright
don't make me say the human shoot dog
world out there got it where am I going
I'm also for the record I'm almost I'm
like okay if I'm not doing great with
bullets here hey you're okay you'll play
some b-ball like mic soundtrack come on
little bow-wow comes others agree newb
get it you see this really stupid meme
that said little bow-wow is actual like
non rapper name is Bower dois word this
is not the time for bowel or have to
shoot that they're gonna chase you no
they're not
where am I going hmmm oh it's red that's
enticing I'm trying to think if it's
worth even like killing them so you can
get items or if like it you're gonna use
more items than you'll get there are so
many [ __ ] dogs I don't know where I'm
going uh
straights at the door at the end what
door
what fine left wait yeah where are you
hey my filling don't miss sorry
it's wait until he's done before you
shoot him so you don't miss or I will
keep running
goddammit I'm gonna dye my dog's okay
it's so frustrating
they're two they're so fast no I don't
it's making fun of me well that's really
insulting you only died once
all right well yeah like once in combat
um what if it's gonna if the autosave is
gonna keep you downstairs or if you
could grab your submachine gun from the
saver and before you come down here I
mean you were fine there was just too
many of them like there was at least
five and they take like probably four
bullets apiece which means I can't shoot
them yeah I think I never just like
three but for some reason that last one
took more they're darting around they're
just this is really far back it's not
it's right upstairs
or the elevator but you haven't even
used the keycard to open this and get
mr. X down here yeah what are you doing
you can go get those submachine gun if
you want to if you'd feel better it's
yeah down the left and then up the
elevator it's just like backwards I feel
like I've just wasted no cuz now what do
any more quickly next I also am on
caution it might be worth it for me to
eat one green herb just to like get on
great unnormal or do you think I should
do that I would just wait until you get
down to read again use the
red-green-blue combination because then
you'll take less damage near the dogs
okay and this way hopefully now that you
know mr. X is coming you won't freak out
I am this time and also you don't need
those I don't know why another board's I
think still bring the grenade launcher
in case oh great
and maybe like another how many SMG
bullets yeah besides like 40 I only have
yeah I have 20 on me and I think I have
another 320 we're under the gun powder
under that should be more than enough
what 120 should be more than enough
anything else
maybe one more green herb if you have it
or no you're gonna grab one down there
anyway don't don't fill your inventory
with two after the a what I'm sick of
them I hate dogs in games in this game
look that's got a okay I'm requesting
fan art of Mary locking and loading an
Uzi saying those dogs would get effed in
the a or say gee 87 at he's ready
I don't it sets me to shoot them safe
and they're squirrely and they're
running all or over the place those dogs
are gonna get effed in the a shut up
that's cool as you reloaded it easy that
was badass
it's like [ __ ] don't turn around this
time I didn't know he was coming
my credit listen to me wait what do you
mean I said he might be right there I
was right yeah you said to don't turn
around well I meant
don't turn around right into him I'm
sorry I should've clarified god it's
okay you got it this time this is the
stupidest
oh jesus that guy's gonna you know
around you're good
I knew it ridiculous can he not can he
not like catwalk is it too light
I guess the fire escape would collapse
under him yeah unbelievable that I had
the same thing happened to me yeah like
I I would still yeah you can sneak by
her she had a nice tube top though
where are you we got little idiots I'm
not [ __ ] around here
wait it's not super accurate yeah there
you go I might have sprayed and prayed
just a little bit there so many goddamn
dogs nice I hope you dogs like glad I
actually have no qualms with killing
them behind this gate
ah down Benjie he's dead the delay over
Skype is I never know if you're yeah
whatever you might kill them mixed up I
hate them all right now that I'm not
worried about dogs let's look for prizes
hell yeah you canine murderer prizes I
did kill a lot of dogs it's like you
went into a and like a rest there's a
blue herb to your right
it's like you went into an animal rescue
or read I don't know the lighting is
weird so you went into a pound and just
started hosing everything remember this
from the beginning of the original game
the boss in the dumpster and everything
wait there might be other oh don't use
those to do that what nothing you look
disappointed in me No
is it a dog there's a [ __ ] dog like
dog stand still so I can shoot you okay
is that what you have to shoot them
extra times because dogs have big souls
wait open your mouth or a map okay looks
like you got everything
what a creepy look oh my god
jumpy the guffin for the record there
there's something out there dogs uh
you're gonna have to fight that big
eyeball thing again I'm not ready I
don't have enough thingies I have one
grenade yeah you see the movie slither
no it's like my favorite horror movie
has Nathan Fillion in it um sorry did
you check the is the courtyard clear
there's scratches on the door yes in the
movie he has one grenade that they find
early in the movie and it's like that's
gonna come back right and so he's got
like a huge gross boss coming up won't
spoil it for me and he's got this one
grenade you should see the movie oh he
put in his butt and then makes the
monster swallow him and then it blows up
in his stomach
that is a spoiler
I only I don't have a lot of these your
pops it's like a horror version of Good
Will Hunting I'll have what he's having
yeah it's just like alien where's the
little thing that jumped out of it
I just keep going hello my baby hello my
honey hello my ragtime girl never family
guy no it's from Spaceballs oh that's
right god damn it and it was a parody if
you're reading this go call police
boogeyman here eating everyboby
many bark boogie bands help they're
coming help me Mommy man that guy's an
idiot when you if he types like that
Leon's been here how come he mommy the
booby man is he all it was someone on
the table where's the little girl
stuffed armadillo this guy likes tech
sit down me too much you just don't meet
that many nice taxidermists and games
true Oh No nobody won no I don't want to
know basements are not good like never
she remembered the same scenario in re 7
where you see like this hole in the
ground and you go down it and the first
thing you do is see this like gross
little body like stuck on a pipe no in
seven it's this it's the one with the
mom so she like oh yeah I think some of
the very very beginning of that game
where Ethan is down there or Ethan's
cameras down there ever
- oh there's movie that game is so scary
when you go down the hall and she's like
scurrying away you know they did that
I'm like it's all calculated no nope
okay here's a gun
take it and shoot yourself in a head and
then I'll do the same good luck it's
every woman for herself sherry yeah it's
so are you Schmidt I only have to be
faster than you sherry here's your gun
or something
I'm not your dad
as Abe Lincoln's wife said after my
American cousin that's the end of that
[Laughter]
that's the same pot as the Code Veronica
they're zombies his dad father Steve
wake up wake up
we're sherry sure sure he's fine I
prefer vodka what happened to her we
have to assess the situation who are you
I'm Claire
excuse me where is she
hello what Oh Annette tell me what
happened to William I don't know looks
like I'm gonna tell to swim can you help
me find Sherrie neither of these people
are assisting with going the
conversation it's already a Blastoise
questions everything's under control I
need to find share my daughter is not
your concern just not sherry go Sherry's
got some bad parents Oh saw it okay
wait wait wait don't go down there yet
check around up here first you might
have already got everything in this make
sure it's blue to me to go in the office
or no yeah
I'm not allowed to save
so there's probably a reason that they
chose families to experiment with the
virus cool well they're giving me the
opportunity to maybe I need that I was
gonna say I'd rather have like a full
heal and then I can but combine the blue
and the green but I don't have any more
reds but I have a full RGB here I would
take that over the first dates no no
don't do that
first dates price good I'd say get rid
of that blue hmm
combine the blue and green and then keep
that as well and then I have a grenade
my field it's your SMG for now I mean
I'd rather have it okay well at least
use your handgun for now okay why can't
you use that typewriter this because if
so that's it this is a good time to end
the episode I'm trying to think of why
oh there you go I don't know why maybe
you had to read that thing first or what
is that a saying maybe what I don't know
can fill a [ __ ] basement
well yeah good fan art so you're
incorrect I just want to see that Uzi
fanner okay cool so do I have done ah
let's save it
don't don't spoil her don't spoil this
you just want to see what's coming next
because you're [ __ ] frightened I am
wait there's just a microphone facing it
like as if the computer was on a podcast
shape back in here welcome back to dead
air GameSpot's horror podcast
okay oh yeah you saved sweet
so wait everybody thank you for joining
if it's Saturday for you timezone wise
then I have a good rest of the weekend
if it's early Sunday morning thanks for
joining us so late as always we'll be
back next week with more our resident
Knievel what's going on next week you're
coming up to a whole section of the game
mr. X is dead for now nah just kidding I
feel like he's just a constant fear for
whatever reason I'm not as afraid I am
afraid of him but I'm not as afraid of
him as the guy in our III as the Nemesis
for whatever reason they're both [ __ ]
awful then get more control on this game
better control yeah it's almost like
because game design back in the day they
basically could design it in a sense or
it's like well I guess you just [ __ ]
now and you like you know you've lost
it's like more stressful than this one
where they've like hopefully designed it
in a sense that I can't escape unless I
forget to like avoid him two times and
yeah cool everybody thanks as always for
joining say gee Ava David Hart or Jimmy
circus I'm expecting the fan art I
requested that be I'll be forever
appreciative but we'll be back next week
like 99% sure I'm Rainer stop in the
comments below always puts the discord
link in there and he's been oh we didn't
do stats this week like we said we would
are you able to pull it up right now or
should I I could do that let me pull it
up not much let me let me put up yeah
kill time do a monologue of some sort
was a cold day how's Portland are you
liking it living there it's really cold
today actually and it's super windy and
I have snow and uh my boss your former
boss like is importing a lot and there's
a lot of snow wherever he's
I think he's in Bend maybe no look how
windy it is the trees they're a Howlin
Dutch into my messy window with my
Pikachu but ok I don't look someone said
it took 15 minutes into this episode
before Mike provided misdirection is
this a record that was Cody Franklin
please sir your item box okay here we go
knitted Shepherd a longtime friend of
the show Mary is going to be seeing mr.
X from the corner of her eye for the
rest of the week playthrough stats how
many deaths do you think you have well
ok before this episode do really so this
snipe three right where I don't think
you're gonna count Sherry's chief irons
stuff maybe I don't know we'll see what
Nathan - that's right so three total
deaths that's pretty good you're like
halfway ish through the game I did dogs
firm kills including last episode in
which you had 6 you have 37 kills which
are liquors you got chewed on by zoms 7
times 12 helped recoveries I'm sorry I'm
reading this wrong I'm Nathan already
compiled you have 31 kills 6 chewed on
bazooms 10 health recoveries 22 saves
but again that's kind of our thing I
mean I don't see a problem Mike once
again lying about playing the game
totally yeah
it's half people saying I don't think
people real realize how long this series
has had that dynamic and then there's
other people saying he needs to get good
[Laughter]
cool sweet good good stuff well thank
you guys for joining us and adding all
that good stuff in there cuz it's good
to remember and and be reminded we also
got some really positive tweets this
week from people who just like some
I'm say like that the show is good and I
like it some some motivation and or some
positivity and that makes my day cuz I
think a lot of this like we do this
obviously like Mike and I enjoy this
series and we like you know spending
time with each other each week playing
it but I think we also do it for like
the camaraderie that is like we enjoy
scary games and just like this mutual
connection of res and evil so I think
it's awesome and I really am glad that
you guys are on the journey with us yeah
and then as a last note in case people
did not see somehow res evil for res
evil one REE masked remake and res
equals zero remastered are all going to
Nintendo switch in the coming months
[Music]
yeah yeah just another I've literally I
think rising before even more than
Skyrim is the game I own more than any
other game really
I have ps2 GameCube PC ps3 like
downloadable there's one more and I'm
missing the Wii version which is
actually really good like the with the
wand the aiming is awesome that's five
[Music]
yeah but anyway thanks everybody for
joining us we'll see you next weekend
maybe I'll have played this game by then
and thank you guys
[Music]
have you played the game maybe once or
twice